Candid Truth
What up everybody? Thank you for joining
us at Candid Truth. We're going to talk
about the truth and we're going to get
candid with it. Tonight is a very
special show. I want to introduce you
guys to my friend Randy Smith. He is an
author of some very interesting books,
some very controversial books, some very
educational books. So what's up Randy?
So glad to have you on the show, man.
Hey man, I'm glad to be here. Thanks for
having me.
Of course, man. So Uh I have a question
because we have met, we've hung out
different uh different events and things
like that, but I never really got a
chance to like hear your whole story,
hear what got you into all this, what
kind of
when was the time when you had that kind
of eye-opening revelation about some of
these things because Lifting the Veil,
that book is so deep and in-depth and
right up my alley. A lot of the the
people that are watching, the viewers of
this channel would eat that stuff up.
You know, as most people do. I've I've
had several moments of not exactly doing
what I should or living the way I
should, kind of going off on my own
path, but I've never turned away from
God or questioned, you know, whether or
not there was anything to believe in.
It's not always been exactly where I
needed to be until the past several
several years
um when when all of this the awakening
started and I
I don't know. It's it's so strange how
some of these topics can
strengthen your relationship that's
already there with God. Um because it
certain topics reveal and make him so
much more real to you and it's just it
it's like it's almost a key. It it's
almost like a skeleton key if I can use
that word
Yeah.
um to to unlock an unshakable faith.
So it is very interesting some of the
topics that I'm sure we'll get into
later tonight.
Yeah. I mean, I can identify because I
was raised Christian.
I wasn't getting good answers from the
church, so I thought, well, the answers
must be somewhere else. Always was a
truth seeker.
Um but then ultimately
that road was hopeless and empty and so
gave the Bible a chance, gave God a true
chance and became a believer, but I like
didn't know what to do with it at all.
So
for 8 and 1/2 years
I still live like the world. I was
smoking marijuana daily, drinking daily,
uh
rapping like at shows, doing all that
stuff on stage, fornicating, the whole
lifestyle that comes with being a rapper
and having a clothing line. And so I was
doing all that stuff
as a self-professed Christian.
Um
So when the blinders kind of came off
for me, December 2011, it was like in an
instant stood me up out of my seat.
Um
it made things more real for me, too,
because I was like, "Whoa." Cuz of the
stuff that was revealed was like New
World Order. Not just There's a lot of
elements to what that is, but New World
Order basically with all the symbols of
every major corporate logo being satanic
and all these subliminal messages that
are in the music and the movies and
cartoons and
and uh police state and all this kind of
stuff that's like there's about to be
there's there's coming an unrolling of
total enslavement, worldwide
enslavement, one world government, one
world religion.
And that kind of woke me up, shook me up
a little bit because I was just kind of
living how I wanted to live and
I was deceived. My cousin was telling me
that my life was blessed. He said, "Hey
man, you got all the girls like King
Solomon. You got uh all the all the
alcohol. Jesus turned water into wine."
He said, "You got, you know, every green
herb bearing seed." And so he was
speaking to me like the serpent in the
garden, you know, uh 99% truth, which is
not truth. And but when this awakening
happened I was like, "Wow, we're
actually living in the book of
Revelation and I can see it." And I
remember Christians telling me all my
life that we were living in the last
days and they had those movies like Left
Behind and all that. And to me I was
like, "Ah man, this is some like way in
the future type stuff." But in that
moment I was like, "Whoa, like we're
living in it." And when I started
sharing what God revealed to me with
other Christians
they thought I was a conspiracy theorist
and that was
disappointing because it's like
now I'm finally seeing what you guys
have been telling me my whole life and
now you don't see it.
That was pretty crazy.
It's like, have you read the book that
you're preaching from, you know? Cuz
it's a lot of things that we believe do
get labeled as conspiracy, but it's
it's in there and it's playing out. It
it's a lot I think we're a lot further
along than than a lot of people realize.
Yeah.
But at the same time, I think we may
have a little more to go than what
people realize before certain things
take place, but we are definitely on the
train.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Lifting the veil, signs and symbols,
that man, that cover alone is so
intriguing. Like anybody that's
in our
circle of influence or our social circle
would be like, "Yeah, I want to read
that." Cuz you can already tell like
what it's about. For me, I know Lifting
the Veil, Signs and Symbols. I haven't
read the book, but just the topic of it
definitely was uh
laying the foundation for me and then
once you see it, you can't unsee it. And
so
because that's the foundation, let's
talk about some of that. You have some
slides you want to share. This Is these
like parts of the book or how is this
working?
Yeah, it's a it's covering it's a very
high-level overview of some of the
topics that I go in depth with in the
book just to kind of give you a road
map. We can take a look at those and
I'll see some of the different topics
that are there. You know, the I think I
open the book with the quote from
Confucius that signs and symbols rule
the world, not words nor laws.
And um there there's never been a truer
statement than that. And um once you
like you you were saying, once you see
that, you can't unsee it and it will
change the way that you look at the
world. But that's not necessarily a bad
thing. Yep. It's so true because
symbols are universal. Like language, it
depending on where you're at, people
can't even understand you, but all
around the world when people see the
golden arches, they know that's
hamburger, fries, that's McDonald's.
Right.
And that's a simple uh symbol, but it's
an illustration of how powerful a symbol
is. You see that you know, the yellow
golden arches
you know that that's food or whatever.
And and um there's a lot of power in
that stuff. There's there's triggers
with these things. Like I I it's worked
on me before. I've been I remember one
time I was working at a valet and I
parked a car and I was walking back and
I was just looking at the ground while I
was filling out the ticket and in my
peripheral, beyond my hand, I saw a
wrapper for a candy bar and I without
even reading the words, you know, it's
in my peripheral blurred vision
I knew what it was and I instantly
craved it. Like right away, it was like
a trigger. Like, "Oh man, that sounds
good." And I didn't even have to read
it. I mean, it was just like blurred in
the background.
And that's the way symbols are. Symbols
have meaning, they are triggers and um
they also tell you a lot about um who
your allegiance is to.
Absolutely.
us, you know, there's there's some
controversy around the symbol of the
cross. Things like that, but
when you see a person wearing a cross
you automatically assume that person is
probably a Christian or at least
identifies as a Christian.
Two lines and yet
atheists hate it. You know, they they
can't stand to see that symbol. And as a
as a believer, you see that and you're
like, "Hey,
uh you a Christian?" Like it's like So
symbols it's like a it's a language in
itself and you don't even have to it's
universal. Like you can see that symbol
any anywhere around the world and it
means the same thing.
Yeah, and it's and it's oftentimes
there's there's double meanings to the
symbol, you know. There is a there's a
face value, this is what this means,
but with someone with certain
allegiances or certain ties, when they
use that same symbol, it means something
completely different.
Um so I there's actually a section in
the book that I don't cover on the
slides to where I have an encyclopedia
of just symbol after symbol and it's
breaking down what it means.
Uh no, it's um it's this book here. It's
Lifting the Veil. I actually have a
section in there to where I include an
encyclopedia of symbols and I give their
origin. Mhm, yes.
I give the origin of it, what it means,
what it means, you know, at face value
and then the esoteric or the hidden
meaning to that symbol. That's what's
up.
And um I I I think it's so important to
at least familiarize yourself with the
most common ones, which is one of the
reasons I put the book together to start
with because whether people realize it
or not, we are assaulted with witchcraft
every single day. Oh yeah.
The the symbols are everywhere.
We are hit with something that's called
sigil magic. That's the way that these
powers behind the scenes operate. Yep.
And we're all victims of uh trauma-based
mind control, whether we realize it or
not. And I actually have an entire
chapter based on that. Wow.
Um I've got a couple of videos on my
channel that talk about that as well to
kind of break down how you, Mikey, are a
victim of trauma-based mind control
Definitely.
just about every day if you go out of
your house at all. So it's a it's a very
interesting topic and there's a lot of
topics like that that uh we can dig into
and I do dig into with that book.
Dude, that is awesome. I can't wait to
see what you got for us right now.
Well, I mean they all started with a a
desire for forbidden knowledge. You
know, the the serpent in the garden,
that that's exactly what he used to
tempt Everybody says to tempt Eve with,
but he tempted Adam and Eve with it.
Adam through through Eve. So, I like I
always like to take a look at
some of the lies that Satan told Eve.
And it's like the the lie of did God
really say? Do you think he really meant
what he said?
And then And then there's a promise. Oh,
yeah. Even now. Even in churches. Did
God really say you got to keep the
Sabbath or something like that, you
know? Like all kinds of stuff. Yeah,
there's a certain religion that kind of
removed the Sabbath commandment and then
broke another one into two so they could
keep 10 and we'll talk about them, too.
But I'm I mean
Yeah, there's a certain religion that
kind of removed the Sabbath commandment
and then broke another one into two so
they could keep 10 and we'll talk about
them, too. But I'm I mean it it's
absolutely
it's mind-boggling how many times you
hear did God really say?
Well, yeah, it's here in the word. Why
don't we read that for what it says it
is and not try to reinterpret
everything, you know?
Um and then he promised them that they
would be like God. That that they're not
going to die. So, we we have a subtle
eternal life promise
there, but then we have that if they
access this forbidden knowledge, it's
going to make them like God.
And these are these are three lies that
we still hear today, every day. The the
the whole transhuman movement is a quest
for eternal life and to become like God.
So,
all of these thousands of years ago,
these lies that Satan told Eve are still
being whispered in our ear
by Satan and by his agents.
And sadly, many people are falling for
it. Yeah. Um and and it's all as a quest
for forbidden knowledge. We hear a lot
about enlightenment. And that's what my
next slide is on is it is different
enlightenment periods because everybody
wants to be enlightened one way or the
other.
It's not always a good thing, especially
considering who they believe the light
bearer to be.
I was thinking about that.
want that light. That's true. Yeah, the
light bearer.
Uh I was just thinking about what you
were talking about with transhumanism
and stuff. Um
we actually don't really hear that much
about it anymore, but it's it's more
subtle
with like AI and stuff because
and you know, this is a crazy topic
because anytime
we use chat GPT or
you know, make a image or anything, like
people are like, this is demonic or
whatever.
Uh I don't think the technology itself
is demonic. I think
all technology at one point in time was
looked at like it was magic or or
satanic or something. And honestly, when
you really look into it, where did the
technology of the phone come from?
Alexander Graham Bell was a
spiritualist. He created it to try and
communicate with spirits. He was trying
to prove that you can listen to spirits,
but
we use that technology, we can use the
phone and we can communicate with people
and share the gospel with them or
go rescue them if they're in trouble or
whatever. So,
it's it's a technology that's being used
for good and evil.
It's a tool. You know, I I did a video
on AI and you know, the whole premise
was is it demonic? And it's kind of it's
kind of a yes and no question because
it's a tool like anything else. It can
be used for good,
but it is a terrible deceptive gateway
for evil as well.
And I believe that it's used at
different times in different ways to try
to reach certain impressionable minds.
I think we've got a mutual friend, Josh,
and his son, the experience they had
with AI.
Um I was able to produce
Go ahead. People bring that up all the
time. They're they're like
that experience that was on video.
And that's the thing, like
there's nothing evil about a a piece of
cardboard with the alphabet on it, but
when you pull out a Ouija board and put
an oracle on it and say, okay spirits,
like I want to hear I want to
communicate with you,
you're telling you're giving the spirit
world an invitation at that point. If
you pull open chat GPT, it's all the
more of a
a great tool for the enemy to use. If
you start asking, hey, are you a fallen
angel? Like
hey, I want to talk to the dead or
whatever. It's the same thing.
Um there's no
demonic power in it unless you give it
that power.
And so,
what I what I think about AI and all
technology is ultimately it does fall in
the hands of evil.
And so,
you can use a knife to cut an apple or
you can kill somebody with it. It's not
the tool that's evil.
But the reason I'm even bringing this up
is because I think that
with the transhuman and all this kind of
stuff
is that Satan is offering that
that same deception that you can be as
God.
Who wants to live in the real world when
you can put on some VR goggles and just
speak things into existence? Imagine you
put on the goggles, all you see is black
and then you say,
I want to be at the beach.
AI builds you in the scene.
Oh man,
I want Megan Fox out here. Here she is.
Like oh, I
I want her to look like this or
whatever.
You are God. You're speaking things into
existence and who wants to live in the
real world?
And I think that Satan is is going to be
building that, this metaverse where you
speak things into existence.
And a lot of people are going to fall
for that. I mean, people already they're
trapped in their phones and all it is is
like videos and stuff.
are. Yeah. Yeah, it's it is a
it it appeals to that inner nature of
wanting to control everything. We we
always want power that's just out of our
reach. So, if we can get that virtually,
it's a little easier to accept and more
people will fall for it. I think you're
100% right. Yeah, and I think it's going
to be
people are going to
say, well, you know,
if
I don't know how to say certain words
without being flagged or something, but
someone who's like minor attracted, they
can actually play out their fantasies in
that world and they won't actually be
harming anyone. So, now you're just
opening up Pandora's Box to do any the
most sickest, most debaucherous things.
I mean, I was a victim of that when the
internet first came out. I remember
going to all the websites and just
watching the craziest stuff, you know,
shock value, like Faces of Death and
seeing people
be you know, real murders and all that
kind of stuff.
And it's just going to get insane. But
yeah, he's still offering that same lie.
You can be as God and that knowledge is
good, even if it's seeing somebody be
killed.
God didn't God wasn't keeping us from
knowledge. He was keeping us from the
knowledge of evil. He didn't want us to
know those things.
Yeah, but even even in the beginning, he
made a way
of an escape for when we did find those
things because with him being the
merciful, all-knowing father that he is,
he's like,
there's potential here for them to mess
up. Yeah. I don't want to lose them
forever. Let's go ahead and put a plan
into motion. Amen.
And um out of all of the books that I've
written with with lifting the veil here,
and we'll go ahead and say it tonight,
that is that's the most important truth.
Out of all the all of all the secret
truth that you may learn, the most
important truth is the truth of the
Messiah
and having a right relationship with God
the Father through his son.
Um without that, everything else that
you learn about it, all the cool stuff
that that that we read about and then we
want to explore the giants and the
cosmology and all of that, it's useless
if you don't have a right relationship
with the Father through the Son. So,
that's what I always point back to as a
continual message in the books,
regardless of how controversial the
topic is. That's one truth that doesn't
change. Amen.
So, we we can get into the next slide
when you're ready here. And that is a
controversial truth that Jesus is the
only way.
is. Yes.
It's the only way.
Ooh, that's controversial right there,
bro.
Yeah.
So,
Wait, was there something that you
didn't Was there a point you didn't talk
talk about on that one?
No, I don't think so. I think it was
just the the basic three lies that you
hear and we're still hearing them.
So, throughout history,
we've had different enlightenment
periods. And
Adam and Eve, I believe, was the first
enlightenment event. So, therefore,
I'm going to say a trigger word here,
but I believe Adam and Eve, according to
the definition of the word, were the
first Illuminati because Illuminati
means to be illuminated or enlightened.
It's not It's not Beyoncé. Yeah. And
it's not, you know, all of these
celebrities, they're not the Illuminati.
They're definitely puppets having their
strings pulled That's right.
by the the powers that control. And and
we'll talk about actual historical
evidence and records of that
organization coming into existence. But
um I believe that they were the first
enlightenment event when they ate that
fruit of the tree and their eyes were
open to knowledge that they weren't
intended to have and we see the results
of that.
That's a good point.
And then the second enlightenment event,
based off the the way that I research
and and read the scripture, would
definitely be the Tower of Babel. Um
with Nimrod and his wife, Semiramis or
Semiramis, depending on how you say it.
Um, you know, the the whole goal there
was
they wanted to build a tower to heaven.
And depending on what what you read or
how you research that, the goal was for
Nimrod to become God, to replace God. He
was already worshipped as a god on
Earth. Yeah. So, he was ready to take
his throne to the heavens.
Um
and then we have the the third
enlightenment event uh around the second
century with the introduction of
Gnosticism.
And um we still see that
prevalent in every aspect of society
today.
Almost everything that you watch or read
from the secular market has a gnostic
twist to it. Yeah. Uh to where God is
the is the bad guy and and the real good
guy is is either Satan or or some demon
or or what we would typically call a
villain. They're actually the hero of
the story.
God is this big baddie that didn't want
us to be able to do anything. So, it's
always an inversion of the truth and we
see that um you talk about it a lot. You
guys are doing excellent job with
breaking that down. It's everywhere.
Yeah. And um I believe that's when
things really just kind of launched
themselves into motion was when that
Gnosticism began to
incline in popularity.
Yeah, and it's
it was around in the Bible days and um
Oh, yeah. the New Testament stuff they
mentioned the the Gnostics that forbade
marriage and eating certain meats and
things which was pleasurable foods
because the Gnostics believed that
your fleshly body is like evil and
you're supposed to
keep I don't know I I don't I don't even
know. It's a little bit twisted. I I
mean I mainly know their belief system
but of uh
that Lucifer was
the the good angel that freed Adam and
Eve from a tyrannical God that put them
in this
perfect paradise but
yeah, they
they believed like pleasure was evil
somehow and so pleasurable foods and
even marriage was forbidden.
And that's what you see still today with
monks
um and uh and Catholic church certain
other yes, yes, definitely.
nuns and the monks and all that stuff.
Mhm. But that was a really good point
about the apple because
even today you still see that symbology
and I said apple I know it's a fruit but
it's always Got you. illustrated as an
apple.
Um Mhm.
and you see it in music videos and
movies and they they always allude to
that apple. And I always knew, you know,
I I've always just thought of it as um
it's it's glorifying sin. It's it's
glorifying the devil.
But really they're
they're lifting that fruit up as
knowledge. As this was the original time
that we actually got obtained knowledge
was through that forbidden fruit. You
just now
really made me see that. That's awesome.
Yeah, it's like I said, everything is
connected. It's it's all
it's the trailer for lifting the veil.
That's one of the the scenes that I have
is the serpent slithering through the
garden to to open that up. Wow. Um and
and the whole presentation of of the
forbidden fruit. And like you said, they
always use an apple to represent that
but it is
in everything.
Um and and it's like they are holding
that up. There's more for you to know
and my last I can show you how to find
out. Yeah, exactly. Our phones are our
our our
I use Windows but
the window to the soul.
It has it has its own issues, yes.
Right. Bill Gates, he's not a innocent
saint either.
Oh, definitely not. No.
And um I I don't get too much into just
those individual people but I like to
talk a lot in the book about the
organizations that those people helped
to push forward.
And the thing with oh, it went off the
screen. Oh, you want to see that?
Yeah, the the thing with the
enlightenment when it come around in the
second century was
people were hungry for that knowledge.
And then somewhere between the fifth and
the 10th century
we witness what we call the
enlightenment movement. Oh. It picked up
momentum as people turned from the truth
of God's word in order to be illuminated
with sacred knowledge because for a
while around, you know, during Christ's
time most of the occult and those
practices they went underground. It
wasn't as out in the open.
But after Christ ascended
in the second century you had all the
Gnosticism picking up which just
steamrolled and picked up momentum until
it led us into this enlightenment that
we're looking at here. And mankind by
the tens of thousands forsook God and
they turned to the light bearer who is
none other than Satan himself. Mhm. Um
and around 1096 AD you had the Knights
Templar that were formed under the
guidance of the Pope at the time.
And all of this is in the book Lifting
the Veil and in a whole lot more detail.
Like I said, I just kind of wanted to
skim the surface here.
And the Knights were led astray and they
actually began to follow the teachings
of Kabbalah
and they began to teach Gnosticism
within their ranks. They started
following the hashish. I believe that's
how you pronounce that Muslims. And they
would become extremely violent after
smoking the hash and go on killing
sprees and binges killing anyone who was
opposed to their faith.
So, with all of that happening with the
Knights, um a majority have become so
depraved that they actually taught that
the Baphomet or Satan was actually God.
Here's where that gnostic twist came in.
Wow. And they required the new recruits
to perform sexual acts in front of a
cross or to urinate or spit up on the
cross. Wow. Now, this led to ultimately
the Pope at the time found out about
this and in my book I go through like
the historical tracings of that.
And um
when they were exposed once again the
occult was kind of forced back
underground
until around the 18th century.
And um the 18th century was coined the
age of enlightenment. See, it's it's
always enlightenment, illumination,
always gaining this knowledge.
And the first organization to go by the
name of the Illuminati was formed on May
1st, 1776
Interesting.
by an Amschel Moses Bauer
who later changed his name to Mayer
Rothschild
and began to set up the first Rothschild
world banking system.
Interesting.
Now
yeah, I mean he forsook his Jewish
heritage. He began to call himself
enlightened as he went about building
not only the Illuminati which was
established on May 1st but also the
banking systems that we still have in
place today.
Now, um
it's I don't think it's a coincidence
that in June of that same year America
was founded.
Um and this happened to be exactly 1
month after the founding of the order of
the Illuminati in Europe.
And uh this leads us to a chapter in the
book that talks about Freemasonry and
the founding of America. Cuz we all know
that George Washington was the first
president of America. But what many
people don't know is that he actually
had the following to say about this
nation.
It was not my intention to doubt that
the doctrines of the Illuminati and the
principles of Jacobinism had not spread
in the United States. On the contrary
no one is more fully satisfied of this
fact than I am.
Wow.
And um I have all of that information,
you know, kind of backed up in my work.
Everything's cited in the book when I
pulled from certain sources.
So, it's known that George Washington
was a Freemason and that he held and
practiced Masonic beliefs. We have
portraits painted of him Yeah. of him in
the Masonic attire.
Um the the apotheosis of George
Washington was just yet another belief
of an ascension to godhood.
So
we can make no mistake.
Oh, really? Yeah, we just went live
like 2 hours ago or something
and was talking about that painting on
the the ceiling. Right? Is that what
you're talking about?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. That's what I'm
talking about. It's talking about the
that word. What was the word of
it's called The apotheosis. The
apotheosis means
uh
to make divine.
And uh he's painted up there in the
clouds with some goddesses and it's
called to make divine. And that that
building that it's in, I can't remember
what it's called now. The Romulus Where
was uh Trump's in
inauguration?
Rob Romulus, something like that. I was
going to say if you hadn't asked me I
think it was something Star Treky
sounding like that.
Yeah.
Well, that building, whatever the name
is, you look up
uh what it was based off of and it
literally says I found an official dot
gov website all about the architecture
of that place and it said it was
based off of a Roman temple. And I was
like they're not just they're not just
telling you like, oh, we took some
inspiration from Roman architecture.
Like, no, a Roman temple where you know
pagan rituals were going down and orgies
and all that stuff and that's what we
put right there in Washington D.C. and
that's where Trump had his inauguration
and that's where
George Washington is painted as a divine
being in the sky.
It's uh
it's insane. It goes right in
to the when we went to Washington D.C.
and
found nothing Christian about D.C. There
was literally
literally statues of Zeus and plaques
with the names of every god but Yahweh
in there.
And it was
it was very eye-opening. Everything
pointed to Rome, everything pointed to
the sun,
and down even down to their
architecture.
Correct. Yeah, I mean basically
Washington is the Vatican. I mean
they're modeled almost you know with all
the same
features and architecture and pointing
to the same gods.
Um and it's very interesting to me that
it's always Rome because we call
ourselves the United States of America,
but I do explore the fact that we're
basically still operating exactly the
way Rome and exactly the way Babylon
before them cuz Rome was just Babylon.
Yeah, I believe I believe we
are the image of the beast. Rome being
the beast, we are a mirror image of it,
and we're we're in
at some point
America is going to point people to
worship the first beast. And that's
that's why I believe that cuz of all the
all the signs that point that way.
Um I can see I can see where you would
get that. What's that?
I said I can see where you would get
that. I do believe that America
um in in unity with the Vatican and the
papery will absolutely usher in
the the beast
and will will we're already working
towards the the oneness of religions.
They're they're going to help bring
about the worship of the beast as well.
Mandate it, if you will. So.
There's
there's some good comments coming in
here. Let's see if I can pop it up on
screen. Somebody said uh check out
Revelation 13:3 in the NIV translation.
Did it not seem like Trump was shot in
the head?
Uh I think that's referring to the beast
will have a deadly wound, and we just
talked about that on the other video,
but
I was saying
I believe that a lot of mainstream
Christianity today has prophecy wrong
and a lot of doctrines wrong and stuff.
It was all because of the counter
reformation, so Martin Luther and and
some other guys
started a reformation of the church,
reforming what you know, the papal Rome
had done, the Roman Empire,
and started this protest movement called
the Protestant movement, and a lot of um
the prophecies that pointed directly to
Rome, which made it really obvious that
Rome is the beast.
Purple and scarlet, decked in gold, sits
on a um
the beast with seven heads. It says
seven heads are seven mountains, and
Rome is the city of seven hills.
Everything points to Rome,
but
they had to start a counter reformation,
and they started coming up with this
futurism. And so they started saying
that no, it
the the Rome, the papacy can't be the
antichrist system, which everybody at
the time believed, uh all the Christians
that were studying this stuff out. And
they said, "No, it can't be because
Revelation is set like way in the
future, and there's going to be like a
one-man antichrist." Which I don't
believe that. I think it's a spirit of
antichrist. That's how the Bible
mentions it as
um plural antichrist. There's many even
now is what it says.
But I was thinking
according to like the Hegelian dialect
and how Satan plays both sides,
I wonder because we already know that
they they made everything go far left to
make the world just
go so evil to where there's no genders,
you got drag queens reading to kids in
libraries, you got you know,
cutting off children's genitals and all
these things to where any sane person
can tell the world is evil.
Now we are at a perfect place to look
for change. We want this nation needs to
get back closer to God because look how
far off we've gone. And this is a the
stage is being set for Satan to appear
as the cosmic Christ, to appear as this
supernatural savior,
being of light that can
do many signs and wonders and
perform miracles and things like that.
But what I think
there has to be kind of a
a boogeyman. This is how all the all the
false flags work. They have the
boogeyman like uh
Osama bin Laden. He's in a cave out
there in some third world country, but
he's bringing down towers, right?
And so I I wonder if Trump is is set up
to be that one-man antichrist like a
boogeyman because yeah, he got shot in
the head supposedly.
He um
he's on the coin for Israel. He's like
wanting to make treaties with Israel.
He's saying peace and safety.
Like he's
he's fulfilling all these prophecies
that point towards the antichrist
system, but he's one person.
What if this is all a huge tie up? It's
all set up so that people will point to
him and say
cuz right now there's a lot of people
think he's like the Messiah. Like he's
going to fix the world, but I think once
they start seeing, "Wait a minute, he is
saying peace and safety, and he did get
shot in the head, and
um you know, he did he is signing
treaties with Israel and all this
stuff."
Then he will be kind of the boogeyman
that Satan will overtake
and appear to be Christ who
killed the antichrist and set up a
perfect world of peace.
I don't know, it was just something that
kind of came to me earlier when we were
talking about that.
And uh
that's
No, go for it.
That's an interesting Yeah, that that's
an interesting theory. Um
I see it a little differently.
Uh and I think that may be, you know, a
topic that we could explore further,
maybe on another show or something.
Okay. Um cuz I I don't think that I
think that Trump is going to be It's
almost like I said with the symbols. It
it's twofold. I think he's going to do
some pretty great things for our
economy.
I think America will seem to get better.
Um but the flip side of that coin is
infrastructure and the system is
definitely being set up to do exactly
what you're talking about, to to bring
in the beast system.
Um
I don't think whatever went on with with
his head, his ear there would constitute
or constitute a deadly head wound.
To me personally, I did a short video on
that. I think it was more of a of a
setup for the perfect photo op, if you
will, to help push him along.
Um
And yeah, something. But um
I can't get into it. We will definitely
get the stream taken down. But uh
I'm actually getting ready to do a
longer video on my thoughts on what he's
what he's actually the role he's playing
because it's not popular to say that
he's playing his part in the drama, but
he's playing his part in the drama. He's
a pawn, man. That part is Yeah,
absolutely. You don't get in that office
without being
at least a puppet, whether you realize
you are or not.
He's definitely got a puppet master
pulling the strings. I'm so glad to hear
you say that.
And I'll save I'll save the rest of my
thoughts for a show on that cuz you
know, I I view the end times a little
differently. Um and I view the the
antichrist a little differently. I think
scripture is
it it gives it to us pretty clear. Um
but like I said, we can get into that
Yeah, man. another time cuz it'll take
us away from
the main gist of what's going on
tonight. Definitely. I did want to pop
one more
uh
comment on here.
It says um it couldn't have been a
literal fruit. Yah had just told us that
all fruit is for food. Yah doesn't
contradict himself, so how was eating
fruit sinful a few days later?
Um I think
you know, Yahweh does not contradict
himself, and what he said, he means what
he said, so
he said
"You can eat of every tree of the garden
except this one." So that's what he
said. But what the serpent said was
"Did God not say you could eat of every
fruit?"
See, that's Correct. Yeah, so 99% truth
is not truth, and what Yahweh said was,
"You can eat of every tree every tree
except this one." Except. Yes. He had a
boundary there. Yeah. He's very
specific, just like um
when it comes to sacrifice, you know,
"I'll accept Abel's sacrifice because it
was the way I said to, but I can't
accept Cain's sacrifice because
it wasn't the way I said. It was still a
sacrifice,
but it wasn't the proper one."
Same with the days of the week, you
know, it could
he said a specific day,
Sabbath, and yet we say oh, not we, but
a lot of people out there say, "Oh, you
can keep any day." But that's not what
he said. So I think it goes in the same
vein as
eating every tree except this one.
Yeah, my my favorite is, "Jesus is my
Sabbath."
Really? Jesus is a literal day of the
week that you're supposed to honor, set
aside to keep holy. Okay.
Yes.
There's a a funny comment here. It says,
"Oh, thank goodness. I thought he was
about to say Trump was is the man.
No, no. I think Trump's playing his
part. And and like I said, you know, in
in fairness, I think he's going to be
good for the economy, at least in the
short term. Um not every puppet
Right, exactly. Not every puppet
scripted to make things terrible. You
have to have that pendulum shift to
swing back in your favor in order to
make you comfortable with other things
that get introduced. So.
Yep.
Yeah.
Very interesting stuff. So, well, we can
make no mistake that the Illuminati
thrived in America. From the previous
quote we saw with George Washington and
that this country was not founded on the
God that we often think it was. Mhm,
that's right.
the the word the word God is is
interesting.
When you look at the meaning of the word
uh in both Hebrew and Greek, Elohim
Elohim and Theos or Theon, depending on
the usage, it it means someone with
authority, a ruler, or a divine being.
And there have been many Elohims
throughout all of scripture and history.
There's been rulers, there's been people
with div- a divine nature or divine
authority. And um you know, you look at
the fallen angels in scripture. They're
called Elohim at some point.
Uh even Satan is referred to as the God,
the word Elohim used of this age.
Yeah. Um so, it doesn't always refer to
the almighty God. So, the phrase In God
We Trust,
which God are we talking about? Right.
And um I break that down in depth in the
book
um to kind of
try to draw a nice circle
from chapter to chapter. I always want
to keep it interconnected. But um on the
on the slides tonight, that was the end
of the few slides that I had that it's
not founded on the God. Yeah, that's the
last one that we think it was.
Um
it's very interesting to me because
America and and the ties to a God Amaru,
they're they're very close. They're
they're
there's so many connections there. And
um in that chapter, I break down the
architecture of Washington and how the
the dome and the obelisk are
representative of the womb and the
phallus, the the womb of Isis and
Osiris. The
the monuments are representative of his
phallic member. Um and you see that in
both the Vatican and you see that in
Washington, as well as other places in
the world. Yeah. Um
it all goes back to the worship of a
false God.
And uh that from there, I branch into
Catholicism and how it was birthed
in Babylon. W- when Semir- Semiramis
began to teach sacrament salvation
through sacraments, the sprinkling of
water, mhm things like that. She began
to teach that you could gain an audience
with God because she was his mother.
And you had the birth of the
mother-child cult right there in Babylon
and we see it persisting
even today. Yep. It's been rebranded as
Mary and baby Jesus. Yeah.
Yeah. Same thing. It's
you know, I just talked about this
earlier, too.
We if you were to ask like
a self-identifying Christian to all
right, you got two choices. You can
either go into the Satanic Temple or you
can go into the Catholic Church. I'm
pretty sure 100% of them would say, "Oh,
I'll go into the Catholic Church." And
it's like but there's really no
difference. It's just
Satan is veiling
his temple in Christianity in these
terms of Christianity like, "Oh, that's
not really planets, that's Peter, Paul,
and
John, you know, and
uh that's not Isis, that's that's Mary."
And um so, Satan has a tackle box full
of bait. And for me, I bought into the
the occult world. I was into the
witchcraft and all that. But some people
might say, "No, that's too dark and
scary." And Satan says, "Well, I got a
new age. Look, it's
colors and love and all this stuff."
and love. Yeah. So, he's he's got a
flavor for everybody, even the
Christians. And he's really
he's going extra hard on the Christians
because he doesn't have to deceive the
lost world. They're already lost.
They're correct.
They're living for the lusts of their
flesh and all that. But the Christian
world, he's working overtime trying to
deceive
their or trying to change their
doctrines and change the wording of the
Bible and all these things
so that we don't understand prophecy, we
don't understand
obedience or any of this stuff.
Right. And and you said it perfect that
the Satanic Temple or Catholicism is
really one in the same. Right. Uh in the
book and this kind of makes me wish I'd
done another slide, but I put a lot of
imagery from the Vatican and Catholicism
as well. And they both share thrones
with upside down crosses in them. Yes.
One is to spit in the face of Christ and
Catholicism, they claim that it's the
cross of Peter, which is still idolatry
at best.
Right. Yeah. But we're we're still using
Satanic occult imagery. Um that's on
display everywhere. They've got statues
of Roman and Greek gods that they've
renamed Saint Peter.
And his feet have been worn away from
the people coming through pilgrimage
pilgrimages and kissing his feet year
after year after year. So again,
best case scenario, you've got idolatry.
You're kissing the feet of a statue.
Worst case scenario and reality,
you've you've got Satanism because it's
it's a false God and we know that those
were fallen angels and unclean spirits
masquerading as those gods.
So,
it's very prevalent within the Catholic
religion that it it's almost it almost
holds hand holds hands with the same
exact imagery that we see in Satanism
and other gnostic and false religions.
Um some very interesting stuff and I'm
sure you've seen pictures of it, but the
big statue of like Jesus
a- resurrecting people from an atomic
blast. Have you seen that one before?
It's behind the pope.
Yes. And his hair out to the side is
making the perfect picture of a serpent.
So, they're doing the whole duality that
you know, maybe Jesus is actually Satan.
You know, I've got pictures of that in
the book with breakdowns and zoom in
sections to kind of give details about
what's going on.
Dude, that is amazing. I want to show
that again if I can. Let's see. Is this
the right one?
No, that's not the right one.
It was on there, but there it goes.
Yeah.
Lifting the veil right here, available
on
rlsmithbooks.com.
I mean, you barely touched the surface.
Some of the stuff that we're talking
about is in here. Um right.
I flipped through this and I was like,
"Wow, we got to talk about this because
you're
you're talking about stuff that our
audience is all about."
What about uh constellations?
in there.
Oh, yeah, real quick before we go to
constellation. I do get in there and I
talk about your entertainment industry,
your music, your movies, your books, and
things like that and show how they show
us exactly what they're going to do
through these things before they do it.
Yep. Predictive
that's how sigil magic works is through
predictive programming. They have to
show you before they can carry out their
actions.
And um I talk about MK Ultra. I talk
about trauma-based, all the different
types of CIA programs with cited sources
and all of that to really tie the
picture together that behind the scenes
of what we think is mainstream
Christianity within the United States
founded on the God of the Bible is
actually something completely more dark
and nefarious
than we think.
So, that's that's what that book in a
nutshell does. It just kind of opens
your eyes to the world around you and it
will cause you to look at things
differently.
Awesome, man. Yeah, the sad part is is
that
the Catholic faith is the world's
largest   Christian
denomination.
I mean,
the majority of people who claim to be
Christian
are in that deceptive
denomination. And then you got a lot of
other
denominations that they still cling to
the same teachings, the same beliefs.
Yeah, it's just Catholic light, pretty
much, you know. Your mainstream
Christianity is Catholic light. Yep.
Sugar-free Catholic.
Yeah. Yeah, very interesting. But yeah,
you'd asked about constellations there.
And um
I don't know where to start with that
one cuz that's a topic that gets you
flagged. You'll get the little Wiki fact
check under this video, I'm sure, when
we're done. Oh, that's like a trophy for
me, man. A medal. Oh, yeah. Yeah. So,
wha- what I want to know is
constellations,
that's that has to do with stars. Like
are you are you specifically touching on
one topic or is that just a cool name
for biblical cosmos?
No, it was just a it's just a cool name
for the book. A buddy of mine, he and I
were talking
about, you know, the book that I was
writing. We were brainstorming
um
name ideas and everything. He said,
"Well, why don't you just call it
constellations, but make the c o n
con, like it's a con job." And I'm like,
"You know what? I like that." That is
cool.
So, um
shout out to Drew if you happen to see
this video. Um, he he helped me come up
with that title. That's awesome.
So, that's that's why it's big con
stellations, because it it's all a con.
Um, everything that we taught and
everything that we think we know based
on the heliocentric model is a lie.
Yeah. And I actually use this book to
bring that out. Um,
cuz I tackle it from from two ways. Um,
I tackle it from a biblical and
scripture stance.
Um, and then I tackle it from a secular,
scientific, and historic. I've got
several chapters for the the Bible,
several chapters for science and
history.
And then the last few chapters, I marry
those two together and show how
the science actually proves the Bible
and that the Bible was talking about
things that we can discover with science
thousands of years ago.
That's awesome.
we we talk about
a number of things, you know, the the
firmament enclosed plane of the earth,
the flood, and how those mechanics
couldn't work on what they say we're
living on.
Um,
and then we go into the heliocentric
model, what all the planets are named
after, Mhm. uh, video links to videos
that I've got uploaded showing NASA
bloopers to where you can see the green
screens, you can see the wires, you see
people fading out of frame because
they're in front of a green screen, they
forget to cut the the green feed, but
they cut the camera feed. It's
It's embarrassing that we're throwing
50, 60 million dollars a day at a
organization that can't do lighting and
green screen all that great. Um, It's I
think sometimes it's almost like they
just
rub it in our face, like, we can be
sloppy about it and they're still going
to believe it. And that's really how it
is. We can show people all these things
and they'll still just be like, nope,
it's real, man. And you're like, yeah.
Dude, if you if this was
any other like TV show or movie and you
saw editing that sloppy, you would be
criticizing it. You'd be like, what?
Look at that. That's so
lame or whatever.
But because it's, I don't know, because
it's supposed to be real and you've
believed it's real all this time, it's
it's that cognitive dissonance kicks in.
You're like, there's no way I've been
lied to
on a scale this big. No way.
Absolutely. And it it starts from the
crib, you know, we've got the the
universe solar system mobiles hanging
over the cribs of children. And then
it's reinforced in every year of school,
at the beginning of every program that
you watch, in movies, and in
commercials, and books, and I mean, it's
Star Wars, Star Trek. Loved those shows.
Mhm. I and I guilty pleasure, I can
still enjoy the story. Yeah. Um, because
I know that it's pure fantasy, pure
make-believe, and it it's fairly fairly
watchable. Yeah.
Um, but what it's reinforced with things
like that to make people
you know, space, okay. So, so yeah,
we've got people in space. I see it
every day. Yeah. But we're not doing the
things they do. We don't travel at warp
speed or go to all these different, you
know, civilized planets, but they're out
there and maybe one day we can discover
those things. I talk a little bit about
that, how they wake up that wanderlust
within children and get you thinking
about things. Yeah.
Um, cuz I give my own story about how
engrossed I was into cosmology. I wanted
to be the first person to discover
intelligent life and and get a signal. I
would ride down
the road in the back seat of my of my
parents' car with a walkie-talkie stuck
out the window trying to get a signal,
you know. I mean, it's it you're
indoctrinated without even realizing it.
I used to think that
wasn't a topic I wanted to accept. Yeah.
I've always been
a believer in aliens and all that stuff
and I used to have this website pulled
up all the time called SETI, I think.
And it was It was like constantly
updating you on signals from space and
stuff and Mhm. Yeah, I totally bought
into the
the um, ancient aliens lie. I mean, when
I became a Christian, I was like, now
what do I do with this whole alien
thing? And because I believe it's real,
wasn't getting good answers from the
church and then
Ancient Aliens said, hey, Moses was led
out of the wilderness by a a beam from a
UFO.
Yeah. And I'm like, whoa, that makes
sense.
And uh, Ezekiel saw a wheel within a
wheel with lights all over or eyes all
over it and I was like, wow, man.
And uh, Yeah.
But see, that's why it's so important to
understand where we live and people say,
no, this is a dividing topic. It's it's
not salvific and it's it's a distraction
and everything negative without even
looking at the subject. They're just
like, no, this is negative because it's
triggering and I I don't want to I don't
want to look at it.
But if you know where we live according
to the Bible and science,
you could never fall for Big Bang,
Darwinian evolution, which eventually
leads to the alien deception.
All of those things, you would never
fall for.
And if the alien deception truly is
Satan's last masquerade, which I believe
it is, the stage is being set, like the
military's on the news daily saying,
UFOs are real, we've seen them every
day. We've been talking to non-human
intelligences. There's drones flying
around. We don't know what they are, but
just keep on shopping, keep on working.
They're getting us used to things flying
around in the skies. They're getting us
used to, like, oh yeah, we communicate
with beings from other dimensions.
They're normalizing it because Satan is
going to appear
in a UFO and he's not going to look like
Satan, he's not going to have horns and
a pitchfork. He's going to come out as a
cosmic Christ, a savior saying,
I can fix all the problems. Lying signs
and wonders, miracles, all these things
that the Bible says that these
miracle-working demons will do and
deceive the world in the last days and
unite humanity in a battle against
Christ.
If that truly is going to happen, which
I believe it is, according to prophecy,
then
understanding where we live is a
salvation issue because falling for
Satan's last deception, which leads to
the mark of the beast, is a salvation
issue.
And so, if you believe that we live in
this ever-expanding vacuum and there's
worlds unnumbered out there, then the
possibility of falling for that
deception is there. When you are
face-to-face with this supernatural
being and you've never experienced
anything like this and you're feeling
overwhelming emotions of love and uh,
tears and joy and healings and miracles,
you're going to second-guess everything.
Maybe I didn't quite understand the
timing of the Bible. Maybe I didn't
understand that Jesus was going to come
so soon or whatever it is.
You could never fall for those things if
you knew that we are in an enclosed
system with a firmament, a glass-like
dome over our head and there's nothing
but water up there. So, it is a very
important topic. In the In your book,
you even say something like
why it's important or something like
that?
It does, yeah. Biblical cosmology and
why it matters. Why it matters. Um,
yeah, because I I I agree with what you
said and there's there's a lot to unpack
there because I always say that
this is not a salvific issue Mhm. until
it is. Right. Because we have I I know
you've heard them, I've heard them, I've
received them, testimony after testimony
of this topic being what wakes people up
to look at the rest of their Bible and
ultimately leads them to Christ. Yeah.
Because it destroys
evolution. It destroys the Big Bang. Uh,
people don't realize that the
heliocentric model
cannot exist unless the Big Bang and
evolution are true.
Those two things that we are very quick
to deny as Christians and say,
absolutely that's not biblical, but so
many people accept the heliocentric
model, they don't even realize they're
accepting a model that can't exist
because they reject the other two things
Yeah.
that Christians reject. Mhm.
So, I do bring I bring that point out
and we come full circle to you saying
that we're in touch with non-human
entities, non-human intelligence.
Right. And I don't know if you saw it or
not, but it may have been on Ancient
Aliens. They say that the way they talk
to these beings is through occult
practices, seances, Ouija boards, uh,
spirit writing.
And and they all have a similar story to
where these entities are telling them,
we're here to help you, Yeah. but we
have a common enemy.
And when that enemy shows up, we're
going to need you to unite with us to
defeat that enemy so we can save you
from the what's destined for your
planet, basically. They get you to find
that enemy
Revelation right there in the video.
Wow.
But we've got an enemy, that's Christ,
and when he shows up, the armies of the
world will unite to make war with him.
No.
That's exactly what these unclean
spirits are telling people in the guise
of aliens. Well, that's why we have a
space force.
Yeah. Exactly. They're being They're
preparing the skies for what? Yes, 100%.
You're about
So, it's all
it's all connected. You know, there's
that phrase again, everything is
connected. Without a proper
understanding of cosmology,
you'll never fully understand
eschatology or, you know, the end times
and the return of Christ, some of that
stuff's just not making sense and we've
got people trying to wrap their heads
around it because they have a
misunderstanding of the foundation
of the front of the book. We skipped to
the back of the book and we don't know
half of what's going on because we don't
even understand what we were supposed to
start with. Yeah.
Man, well said, bro.
Man,
I feel like we touched on some really
good stuff.
Um I definitely want people to check out
your books on rlsmithbooks.com.
Did I say that right?
You did. Yes, rlsmithbooks.com.
to zoom out here.
And uh you do have these on Are all
these on audio or I know this one is.
The Dream Warrior is on audio. The one
that says, I need to update my website,
you're showing it here live, uh coming
fall of 2024, that book is still in
progress. Okay. Um I ran into ran into
some plot brick walls pretty much, but
it is beginning to come again and flow
very quickly now. So, it should be out
definitely within 2025.
Um I'm getting close to sending it to an
editor. I just got to finish a couple
chapters and kind of wrap up the story.
But um
again, I think books like this are
important. The The non-fiction books is
what's what I started with and it'll
always be my passion. As a matter of
fact, I may or may not have another one
that I'm outlining right now.
Uh to talk about some very interesting
stuff.
But um I also want
I I just think it's amazing that you're
doing this because
we love stories. I mean, I think
Jesus made us that way. He taught
everything he taught in stories,
parables.
And
stories are are very powerful. Jesus
could have got on a side of a a mountain
or side of the hill and said uh
just started reciting the 10
Commandments, but that's not near as
powerful as telling a whole story from
beginning to end and showing
you know, there's this
there's a character that did this and
then this happened and then at the end,
you know, this happened. It's just like
the boy who cried wolf. You know, we
teach that story to children because
a parent can tell her kids all day long,
don't lie, don't lie, lying's bad or
whatever, but
a kid doesn't know, well, why is lying
bad, you know, it can get me out of
trouble. That sounds good to me.
Right.
the moral is if you lie, lie, lie, then
when you tell the truth, you won't be
believed. And so, when you hear the
whole story, like, oh, wait a minute.
Yeah, I really shouldn't lie because
people aren't going to believe me when I
tell the truth even.
And so,
stories are so powerful and Satan knows
the same thing.
So, Satan's putting his message out
everywhere. All the movies, all the
games, all the cartoons.
And really, there's not a whole lot
coming out from the Christian world. And
if it is, sometimes it's false, you
know, you got like Left Behind series
teaching this pre-trib rapture thing
that's not even real.
So, I'm so and especially spiritual
warfare, man, what an important topic
for these days because like we were just
saying, there's unclean spirits like
frogs gathering the people of the world
today to fight against Christ. We need
to know how to discern spirits. We need
to know how to cast these spirits out
and this is amazing that you have this
fictional
It's a it's a fictional story, but it's
based on reality of a spiritual war that
we're all engaged in. I love it.
Right. And I I did want to I wanted to
take a minute to hit on that. It is a
fiction story. So, I don't want I don't
want people to get a wrong impression of
it and and get it thinking that it's
going to be like a book about spiritual
warfare, like teaching.
It It is fiction. It's It's a story
that's meant to entertain.
And it's meant to do it in a clean way
that you can enjoy and share with your
children. I've had reviews from
you know, where children have read it,
11 years old. I've had 70-plus year-old
people read it and everybody in between.
And they all enjoy it. Well, one of the
best reviews I received on uh Christian
Sanity from Patheos.com was that it is a
multi-generational book that it spans
that gap to where everyone can enjoy the
story being told. Amen. So, there's
probably some things in there that you
know, someone reading it that's
unfamiliar with fiction or or fantasy
type things, they're going to be like,
well, that's not in the Bible. And And
that's true, but but neither is this
main character. You know, you won't find
her in the Bible running around doing
battle with unclean spirits, but it puts
it in a very entertaining way
while revealing a lot of important truth
along the way. And um in the next book,
you're going to see even more even more
things begin to um unfold within the
universe of the Ashwood Chronicles. It's
going to tie some of the things that
we've talked about together here tonight
into the story in a fun way to where
people will learn it without even
realizing they're learning. This I got a
dumb question. Is that Ashwood
Chronicles, is it based on the same
girl? Is that like a part two or is it
different totally different story?
It is the It's set within the same
universe. Um it is a different
protagonist in the second book. Cool.
And I can't really say a lot about that
without ruining the first book for
people that haven't read it yet. But um
this The Dream Warrior is a novella. It
is kind of like a prequel that's setting
the stage for a larger set of books
within that same, you know, universe.
So, there's definitely you want to read
Dream Warrior if you're interested in
you like that kind of stuff, you want to
read Dream Warrior before The Ashwood
Chronicles is released
because um
you might be a little lost.
That's awesome, man. Yeah. But dude,
thank you so much for coming on here and
sharing all this awesome information. I
know this has been like a super cool
talk. There's been people in here that
were already saying that they enjoyed
what the things we're talking about. And
this is
like divine appointment cuz we literally
were just talking about this same kind
of stuff, so super cool having you on
here and talk about this stuff. And if
you guys want to support Randy, you can
go to the links that are in the
description. There's a Patreon page.
There's You can buy these books on
Amazon. I'm sure you can get them from
his website there the same way.
And I'm a fan of uh audio book and he
has at least this one book in audio book
and it's so well done. Like it's
actually read by a female.
Right? Am I remembering right? Yes.
Yeah.
Audio books aren't cheap. They're
They're the to hire the voice actors and
everything, so that's why the fiction is
the only one that's done that way.
As As Lifting the Veil and the Ministry
grows, I do plan to go back and have
audio books of my non-fiction as well.
But that's something that's going to be
further down the further down the line.
Um I do plan to have an audio book of
the second fiction book for release this
time if possible.
Oh, it's going to be super cool, man.
It's like watching a movie without
watching it. You know, you can do it
while you're driving, which is what I do
a lot of. I do a lot of traveling.
Yeah, man. Randy, do you got any like
final thoughts you want to share or
anything?
No, I just I just want to thank you for
having me on and giving me the
opportunity to talk to your audience
about some topics that we're both
passionate about. Um
we haven't said it yet and many people
may know, but I have a YouTube channel
as well to where I dig into these topics
um
as well. And maybe you can add that to
the video description if you're
comfortable doing that when we're
finished. But it's under Lifting the
Veil, Exposing Darkness. And I talk
about all of the taboo topics that
churches refuse to talk about. They're
not safe for Sunday school. They're not
pulpit material, but they're so
important. And um if you get a chance,
you can check those out. And uh
I'm sure all of you guys are very
familiar with Mikey and Aubrey and the
work they're doing, so
continue to support them and show them
some love cuz we're all doing kingdom
work and everybody plays a different
role. Just like the military. You got
different branches of the military, not
that I'm a
you know, patriot or anything like that.
I appreciate their sacrifices for what
they do. I don't I don't want to go down
a political rabbit hole, but they have
different branches to achieve different
tasks.
It's the same way within the body of
Christ. You've got some people assigned
to do this and others assigned to do
that and some people are doing this over
here, but it's all important and it's
all working towards the same goal. So,
we've got to support each other That's
right.
if we want to see this kind of content
able to keep thriving and growing.
Amen. Man, perfectly said, bro. Thank
you so much and I encourage you guys,
check out his books, man. Check them out
and support him because Christian world
doesn't get enough support. There's a
lot of Christians that are complaining
that there's not a lot of cool Christian
content out there, but then they don't
want to support them as well. So, here's
some cool Christian content. Go check it
out, support him and hopefully he can
continue to keep making more of this
stuff. So, thank you so much for coming
on, bro. I hope you guys enjoyed this
video. If you did, give it a thumbs up.
It really helps. It's a free and simple
way to uh get this video into the
algorithm and help others to see this as
well.
And if you're new, click subscribe. If
you guys want to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got many different
ways to do that through digital formats.
And we got some cool merch. If you guys
want to check out some
uh cool shirts that talk about it's cool
to use your brain and the truth will set
you free and many others that really
helps support this ministry as well and
we cannot do this without you guys. So
we love you. We thank you and we'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.